She would’ve thought two
years was enough time for the
strangeness to rub off, but it wasn’t.
Julianne Moore is an
amazingly talented actress.
She’s an Academy
Award winning actress,
and when she expressed
enthusiasm for the story
and the script, I was just overjoyed.
I was over the moon.
Julianne is so powerful.
She has not only a very particular
beauty, but is someone that can
hold an enormous amount of mystery.
And I think when you work
with materials like this,
with mystery, suspense, fantasy,
thriller, you know, they're all
mixed and combined in this
sort of explosion of memories.
Someone like Julianne can really
hold it and pull it together.
It’s a hugely challenging part because
she’s playing somebody who's
full of grief and full of pain and
often under threat in the thing.
So it’s a very sort of heightened
state she’s in throughout.
Time apparently did nothing but
blunt grief’s sharpest edge,
so that it hacked rather than sliced.